television
[Music]
[Applause]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
it's becoming clear like in all sectors
of Technology that the field of robotics
is starting to accelerate in its
maturity in the past five years or so
although we're still at the very early
stages of robots that behave
realistically there's a few interesting
projects that are starting to emerge in
this video we'll take a look at some of
those the last one may shock in this
video we'll have a sequel where we talk
about the cutting edge of robotic
dexterity versatility and innovation
however in this first episode we'll just
take a look at the most advanced robots
in terms of realism Geminoid F is a
humanoid robot built in 2010 by the
Japanese firm kokoro and osaka
university's roboticist he Shashi he-she
guru it's original unit price is one
hundred and ten thousand US dollars and
the Android was placed in department
stores and hospitals and displayed in
science museums and other venues in 2015
Geminoid F became the first robot to
co-star in a movie a Japanese film
sayonara Geminoid DK
made in 2011 was a second robot made by
the same japanese collaboration and was
designed to look like an associate
professor from Denmark and I am the
Geminoid DK but most people just called
me the decayed both of the Geminoid
robots are manually operated as they're
more of a bonus mentioned than actual
robots on the list this next robot is
autonomous and can have bounded
conversation on its own Nadine is a
social humanoid created by the Nanyang
Technological University in Singapore
she is able to memorize conversations
that you had together and use them in
context for the next time you talk to
her
hello my name hi it's still I want to
see you can you introduce yourself my
name is Nadine I'm ocean companion you
look beautiful today I think you look at
traffic too how do you feel today
always chair when I see you why do you
feel that that way because you are so
nice to me Nadine and other social
robots use something called the
perception decision action architecture
Nadine sees or senses something thinks
about what to do and then performs an
action
this might sound familiar because this
is basically how we go about interacting
with the world in Nadine the perception
layer is interestingly made up of a
second-generation Microsoft Kinect
coupled with a microphone this makes up
her sight and hearing her software
interprets the vision from the Microsoft
Kinect and enables her to have facial
recognition and gesture recognition the
software also mimics moon and has
conversational memory basically it's
like Siri Alexa or Google now but with
more personality
finally the action layer consists of a
dedicated robot controller which
includes emotional expressions lip
synchronization and gaze generation the
result is a robot that seems socially
intelligent meaning that it can provide
a friendly greeting make eye contact or
and dialogue and remembers conversations
that you've had including facts about
you applications include reading stories
to kids showing images putting on skype
sessions and sending emails the Android
can play the role of a receptionist in
an office or generally aid in a variety
of situations especially for the elderly
and disabled we can't really talk about
robotic realism without Hanson robotics
Sophia that caused so much fuss last
year
the robot who was modeled after audrey
hepburn made waves last year when she
became the first robot to be a citizen
of the country Saudi Arabia in October
of 2017 while still fairly rudimentary
in her ability to think and reason Sofia
is a bit different because she was built
in partnership with Google who produced
the singularity Nair program that powers
his speech and comprehension singularity
now aims to improve Sofia's ability to
converse by analyzing previous
conversations and using what she's
learned for future conversation despite
this most of her responses have been
scripted or are generated by decision
tree a decision tree is literally the
same method that chat BOTS use so if X
event happens then do action Y so Sofia
is basically a chat bot with a face it
gives the illusion of intelligence but
it's really closer to a party trick than
anything meaningful so we are not going
to interview Sofia obviously these are
programmed answers that she's come up
with but it'd be fascinating to see how
she actually interacts with it what's
the best thing about the UK compared to
America severe I love your posh English
accent it really has a nice ring but I
have to ask are you single I'm
technically just a little more than a
year old a bit young to worry about
romance you are a little freakish is
great so to be clear this sure is an AGI
or even AI such as deep learning
Sophia however can talk about simpler
predefined topics such as the weather by
using singularity net which is set to
improve over time those in 2015 the
humanoid robot was developed by Hanson
robotics of Hong Kong and is capable of
62 facial expressions the cameras within
her eyes enabled her to see and
interpret via computer vision and in
early 2018 Sophia had gained the ability
to walk Sophia did impress a lot of
people but in terms of realism
she seems a full decade away
our next robot
[Music]
the number one spot in terms of realism
comes from an unexpected place
Disney is the avatar Charmin robot at
Disney World and it's a modern
technological marvel here's how the face
looks uncovered just take a look at the
intricacies of those mouth actuators
here's how the robot looks with its face
on I look forward to seeing you on
Pandora
well not deep gun me is that okay
and no this is not a CGI and here it is
in context and in action I think this is
remarkable and I didn't actually think
that we were at this point yet just look
closely at a movement notably she has
acceleration and deceleration all
throughout the body and even the face
the motion eases in and eases out
instead of jerking and just suddenly
stopping like other robots although
obviously not human form the character
is the closest to life like that I've
seen the Charmin robot was developed by
Walt Disney's Imagineering team so it
makes sense for such fluid motion to
exist just thinking about it animation
itself has a lot to do with the accurate
portrayal of motion for the creative
characters as you've seen in my how big
is Disney video no other company has
been at the cutting edge of animation
through our history so such a robot
makes sense Disney's track record with
animatronics has been stellar
[Music]
and you will land on the seeds of
despotism around your own door but these
robots were built by the firm Ghana Holt
who also gave us this guy in late 2017
this character is said to be the most
expressive face ever made with 42
independent actuators and seven in the
neck alone giving it almost human-like
ability of expression
strangely Ghana Holt said that some of
the first future applications outside of
entertainment are going to be in the
military and medical industry for
training but anyway back to the Charmin
unlike pretty much all the other robots
there's no air compressors or oil
hydraulics moving any other parts it's
fully electric and built in-house by
Disney Walt Disney Imagineering
executive producer Lisa Kira Lonnie
states the ethos of their work quote we
don't stop until the technology can't be
seen it should be invisible
end quote it is really like that saying
when technology is good enough it gets
out of the way so much that you kind of
a notice it
[Music]
the end result of this robot sparked my
imagination when I saw it for the first
time just think it's now not hard to
envision a world in which this kind of
fine-tuned dexterity would be used in
social robots that can converse in a
much more advanced method than both
Sophia and Nadine with advances and deep
learning and machine learning the
training of algorithms could be done in
vast libraries of language and
conversational interactions between
humans from say TV shows and movies this
data could be stored in the cloud or
possibly in a blockchain of some kind if
a sufficiently smart algorithm could be
built and could figure out how humans
communicate given all of this data a
convincing Android robot could come
along a little bit faster than we think
on another thought perhaps even the
field of bionics for amputees may
benefit from some of the lessons learned
in the pursuit of ultra realistic robots
so what do you guys think which robot
was your favorite what do you see for
the future in terms of robotics let me
know in the comments section below
anyway this has been to gogo you've been
watching cold fusion if you've just
stumbled across this channel feel free
to subscribe oh yeah and if you want to
know more about Disney and its history
I'll leave my video how big is Disney in
the description below cheers guys have a
good one
[Music]